[Music]
people forget 1984 and how dominant you
were from new york john mcenroe
sometimes you have to remind folks like
i really was the man
uh
sometimes i do hopefully uh they have
some sort of understanding of tennis
history
here's a refresher
[Applause]
during his peak in the 80s mcenroe was
ranked number one in both singles and
doubles his 149 career titles are the
most in the open era he won 17 grand
slams including three wimbledon titles
you can't be serious man you cannot be
serious
of course the new york native was also
known by the title of super brat thanks
to his notorious temper on the court
this guy's an incompetent fool you know
that
that's what he is that's what he gave
you right you would completely lose it
and somehow go back onto the court
and win
i'm not quite sure how i did that but i
think that's what infuriated my
opponents the most not that i lost it
how quickly i gained it back yeah they
hated that that much bigger point you
brew it up with off the court mcenroe's
personal life was equally dramatic
including partying drug use and a
six-year roller coaster marriage to
oscar winner tatum o'neill you crossed
over into what is our world here at et
when you marry tatum in 86. my kids are
the most important things on this earth
and i'll try very hard to make my
marriage work did you ever do drugs in
front of your kids was it that kind of
thing no we weren't that bad did it take
the focus off of tennis and derail who
you could have been first of all i just
got to say tatum was 22 when when kevin
was born my first son so that's a lot to
ask you know i was expecting because she
won an academy award at 10 and been
through a lot with her dad didn't mean
automatically that she could understand
what i was going through you know i
thought i could have my cake he needed
to i wanted to be a father but i wanted
to be the best player in the world
unfortunately
hosted children i
was never the same player
and that drove me crazy now the 63 year
old father of five has found peace john
is currently the narrator of mindy
kalin's hit comedy series never have i
ever why is sports icon john mcenroe
narrating this tale got a credit mindy
kaling it turned out her father was a
big tennis fan and must have talked
about me a lot and as we see in the new
showtime doc john has been happily
remarried to his wife of 25 years rocker
patty smythe this turns into in the end
a love letter about a man who grew up
and found himself getting a second
chance like a marriage um going through
a divorce kids you know all these things
we can
relate to and um when you come out the
other end and feel like you're better
because of it that's that's a great
feeling
[Music]